hi I'm Mike and I'm here with Daniel and
Roman who are all engineers from the
Android team and we're going to be
introducing a concept called
applications Without Borders with
Android applications can integrate
features and data from other
applications they can also use all of
the hardware sensors on the device
including GPS compass accelerometer and
the camera and of course they can also
use all of the content available through
Web API so now Daniels application is a
really good example of this I'm one of
the engineers working on zebra crossing
an open source library to decode
barcodes using a camera phone we have a
great client for Android which really
shows off how we can integrate with the
system so here's the application running
using the camera preview and now I'm
going to scan a product there we go and
I can open product search by sending an
intent
we can also recognize 2d barcodes called
QR codes let me show you so here's my
business card
which has a barcode on the back and when
I scan it you get my contact info so you
can add me as a contact without having
to type it out or if I cancel out of
there you can do a few other things you
can dial a number using the dialer or
you can send an email to my address my
app also publishes intents so that other
applications can scan barcodes too I
found this which are really useful and I
decided to integrate it into my own
application without doing the work this
is a list of books that I keep with me
in my pocket at all time and I wanted a
way to be able to quickly and easily add
new books to my library so when you
click the add menu I simply fire an
intent that starts Daniels application
and I can now scan a book to add it to
the library and once the book is scan
the application downloads information
about the book on the internet so really
here I created a mash-up that leveraged
the features of both of our application
to create a richer user experience now
Mike will show you a different kind of
mashup now my application mixes together
user created content from the web along
with compass and GPS information and an
embedded map view all into kind of a geo
social stew so we're going to start by
launching the application and when it
comes up we see an embedded map view
this is showing the area that I'm going
to use to search for pictures and it's
centered on my current location using
GPS when you hit the search button it
goes out to the Panoramio web service
and finds the most popular photographs
that were taken in this area now here we
have a picture of the t-rex skeleton
that's on Google's campus
don't ask when you click on that you get
more details about that photo and if you
want to find where that actually is in
the real world you have two choices you
can either click on the map menu and
that will bring up a custom map view
that has a pushpin with the physical
location of where that picture was taken
and it also shows your location using
GPS and if you want to navigate there by
walking you can hit the radar view and
that will give you
a bearing to that statue to that
skeleton so the t-rex is 200 yards that
way we hope that these demos have shown
that with Android you can think about
application development in a
fundamentally different way we have
already seen examples where developers
are building on each other's work to
combine features in exciting new ways
and we can't wait to see what you come
up with